hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
sorry and calm and in this video I want
to demonstrate for you on a patient how
to auscultate the lungs anteriorly and
posteriorly in the previous video I went
over an in-depth lecture about how to do
this along with normal breath sounds and
abnormal breath sounds so be sure to
check out that video after you watch
this so let's get started
first I want to start out showing you
the auscultation side so I wanted to use
these stickers so you can see about
where I'm going to go with the
stethoscope and let me get over these
real fast for you because these are the
little landmarks of where you're going
we have our right leg over here and our
left leg over here and what we're doing
is we're assessing the lungs the right
lung has three lobes the right up or the
right middle and the right lower the
left lobe only half of the left lung
only has two lobes the left upper and
the left lower so whenever you're
listening you want to start out at your
apex up at the top of the lungs right
above the clavicle just slightly above
it right here where you see these pink
stickers then you're going to go down to
the second intercostal space a little
bit over from where your breastbone is
the sternum and this is where you're
gonna start assessing the upper lobes of
the lung then you're just gonna inch
down a little bit and you wolf this is
about the third intercostal space and
you're gonna listen here then go down to
the fourth intercostal space and this is
one of the landmarks for the right
middle lobe your fourth intercostal
space so right here well listen I'm here
here a right middle lobe and then we'll
listen to our left upper lobe then we'll
inch down a little bit and we'll listen
a little bit more to that right middle
lobe and then we're going to be
listening to our left lobe and then
we're gonna go mid-axillary over here to
the side where the armpit is mid
axillary axillary sixth intercostal
space and we're going to be assessing
our lower lobe so it's right here on him
and then it's again right here and
you'll listen there and then um you'll
just inch down a little bit and listen
at the bottom just to assess those lower
lobes a little bit now let's listen to
the lungs with a stethoscope okay before
you begin what you want to do is you
want to perform here
hi Dean introduce yourself to the
patient and tell them what you're going
to be doing and what whenever I listen
to lung sounds I like to listen directly
on the skin with my stethoscope not over
the gown or over their clothing because
you can pick up other sounds that may
sound adventitious when it's really not
and you just get the best acoustic sound
whenever you listen directly on the
patient so you want to get your
stethoscope and you want to listen with
the diaphragm of your set the scope
because that's what picks up the best
sounds and what we're listening for is
we're listening for that full cycle of
inspiration and expiration and we're
paying attention to what type of breath
sound is it is it bronchial vesicular
Branko vesicular if you're not familiar
with those sounds check out my other
videos because I have audio clips where
you can listen to those and we're also
listening for any extra sounds on top of
those sounds like crackles wheezes
Strider anything like that that we may
be picking up and another kids this
skill takes getting used to you have to
practice it over and over especially
when you're listening over these areas
because you're gonna hear the heartbeat
at the same time so you got to train
your ears to listen for those correct
sounds like you're the heart versus
lungs so practice this on yourself and
others so you can get comfortable with
it so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
start at the top and we're gonna work
our way down and we're going to start on
one side and then compare that side
because we want to say say see if we're
hearing the same thing on this side as
we are that side so let's get started
okay what I'm gonna have you do is take
one breath in through your mouth and out
through your mouth
and if you start to get dizzy or
anything let me know and we can slow
down okay we're starting up at the apex
right above the clavicle
now we're gonna inch down to the second
intercostal space and this is where
we're gonna start listening to our upper
lobes of our lungs
so about right there then we're just
gonna inch down a little bit to about
the third intercostal space and listen
there and we're gonna go over and
compare it now we're going to go down
into the fourth intercostal space and
we're still gonna be in the upper lobe
of the left lung but now we're gonna be
in the middle lobe of the right lung so
let's just go down just a little bit and
then we're gonna go over here and
compare and then we'll just go a little
bit do maybe the fifth intercostal space
just still assessing that middle lobe
and I go over here and compare now we're
gonna go mid axillary and we're gonna be
down in our lower lobes now and this
will be at the six intercostal space
okay we're going to compare sides so if
you just want to turn over here we're
gonna go mid acts like a parasite then
we're just going to go down just a
little bit to say in that lower lobe and
then we're going to compare sides now
let's look at the posterior view of the
back here over on this side we have the
left lung and over here we have the
right lung it's flip compared to the
anterior view and what we'll do is we'll
start listening up at the apex of the
lungs again and that's right above
slightly above that shoulder blade in
this area where the green stickers are
then we're going to go and we're gonna
listen between c7 to t3 and c7 is where
you're prominent starts so right here
and we'll go a little bit below it
because c7 to t3 is going to assess the
upper lobes of the posterior side of the
lungs so we'll go here and here then
we'll go down just
bed.this is about where t3 is and then
we'll jump down to round t4 and from t3
to t10 we'll be assessing the lower
lobes in your posterior view you have
more ability to auscultate the lower
lobes then compared to the anterior view
where you're gonna really be assessing
the upper lips so then we'll just go
down listen here listen there we'll go
there and then we'll just go a little
bit mid-axillary almost mid-axillary and
listen over on these sides and then down
at the bottom and over here now let's do
it with a stethoscope now we're going to
listen posterior lis okay let me tell
you a trick with this whenever you're
listening back here as you've learned if
you watch the other lectures you have
the scapula back here and you have the
vertebrae and what you're trying to do
is to get in between that scapula and
vertebra to listen to those lungs and
you don't want to go over the shoulder
blades of scapula while you're listening
to lungs because it's really gonna
muffle out your sound and you're not
gonna hear a lot so what you need to do
is have the patient sort of just move
their arms like this to separate those
shoulder blades from one another so you
have some space to work with so what
we're gonna do again we're gonna start
from top and work our way to the bottom
and we're going to compare side so we're
gonna go slightly above the scapula
listen to the apex then we're gonna go
down in the area where c7 is which is
where your prominence is then we'll work
our way down to where t3 and remember
this is assessing the upper lobe and
then we'll go down from t3 to about t10
and assess those lower lobes so here we
go
and again just take a deep breath for me
in and out
okay and we are done with posterior okay
so that is how you assess the lungs with
a stethoscope now be sure to check out
the other videos in this lung series
like the audio files of the normal
breast films vs. abnormal and the
lecture that covers this material in
depth and thank you so much for watching
and please consider subscribing to this
YouTube channel